[Music]
I'm here to talk about a topic that's
not very commonly talked about in
Silicon Valley because this is the home
of venture capital but we bootstrapped
our company entirely never raised a
single dollar and it's a 22 year journey
and I'm going to talk about some of the
lessons we learnt and I'm going to share
and the biggest one that's there in the
title it's the mindset when
bootstrapping is more than anything else
it's your you have to conquer your own
mind first and then only you are you
know able to build a business first
question how many of you recognize this
SNMP what it stands for I would not be
surprised if most of you didn't know
because it's a very obscure thing it's
simple network management protocol and
this actually is if you look at that was
our very first product actually this was
22 years ago we called it a Java SNMP
API it's really very popular product
right it's popular brand name but you
know it's actually there's a lesson here
for bootstrapping in fact ie I remember
even at that time I mean you're selling
something like this even your mom won't
recognize what this is right actually we
still sell that product by the way it's
still we have a website where we sell
the product but this is a very tiny part
of our business and we sell a lot more
these days when you have probably seen
the Zoho you know commercials watched
all of this those now we call ourselves
the operating system for business and
that's over 40 products in that suite
including this presentation this is
actually made from zoar show our online
presentations
after that as part of the one so that's
what we are known for these days but as
I mentioned we still sell that original
that Java SNMP API and here is the thing
that I liked about that starting there
well it paid our bills it is not a huge
6e market but it paid our bills and it
trained our engineers we learnt how to
do how to build software and we learnt
how to build software outside the
pressure cooker of large scale right we
learn to build you know smaller kind of
software and that's valuable training
and then it taught us business actually
taught me sales and marketing I am an
engineer you know I still know how to
write code but the thing that I had to
learn is how to sell how to market in
fact if I had to go back and redo it
I'd probably learn a little more of the
sales and marketing because that's one
thing that probably in the early years I
had to struggle with they taught us the
business you know how to how to build a
business or run a business and it
allowed us to invest in more software
and more and more in 22 years now we
have built a lot of software and we have
now you know we would be considered one
of the largest private companies now in
definitely largest one of the largest
private software companies in the world
and having never raised money and we are
going to stay private
we are never now that we have tasted
this the freedom we are never going to
go public and SNMP also this thing kept
us alive to fight another day this is
something that I would tell our people
early on that this puts food on the
table and it keeps us alive to fight and
fight and fight and we built from that
experience of staying in business and
fighting living to fight another day and
this is actually something that really I
stress for particularly for a
bootstrapping company you have to find
ask yourself what is my SNMP that's a
good way to ask the question and today
this is our Joe one the operating system
for business and it is the full suite of
sales and marketing and accounting from
email collaboration all of this in one
suite let me give you some simple guys
navigating the whole bootstrapping how
you do this I won't be the person to
approach if you are raising lots of
money and I don't say that this is the
only way in fact it's something that's
important everything I say in this
you should the disclaimer any advice in
any philosophy or to realize that it's
very contextual there isn't some
universal truth that applies to all
people at all times this is what from
our experience what you can learn and
apply it to your context see what you
what makes sense for you and the first
five years for us I was thinking only
one thing that is survive survive
survive survive survive this is actually
true for a lot of startups but
particularly bootstrapping right you you
literally have to bring in the money to
keep the doors open
and if you I know the the most common
thing in business failure is so you just
run out of money simply you an idea may
be good your product may be good your
vision may be good
you keep customers happy you keep
employees happy but if you run out of
money or it's game over
particularly through in bootstrapping so
this is the first thing that I would
tell myself tell our team that we have
to survive if you can survive we can try
we can even win but we first have to
survive and if a market segment is
particularly in a bootstrapped mode
actually if you go back 22 years and
those of you who were old enough to
remember that was the time Yahoo and
Google and eBay they were all born
Amazon they were all young companies at
the time in fact I remember this when we
were starting out Yahoo had not at least
a million dollars in revenue that was
the time and why didn't we go and
compete in that space well all those
guys made Yahoo at raised maybe 20 30 40
million dollars at the time there's no
way we with no money
could compete with them then why didn't
we go and raise money it's not actually
easy even today with all the capital
floating around most people still will
get rejected right most of most people
who approach venture capital are going
to get rejected so and most people who
even apply for incubators are going to
get rejected so the default assumption
you should make is you're going to get
rejected for funding and and so my
advice is how do you build in spite of
maybe not being able to raise money or
maybe you don't want raise money in our
case it was a mix of both I mean we we
knew it is going to be not easy to raise
money but we also may be a you know
early on we didn't really want to be
raising money so you find the market
opportunity that's not heavily contested
heavily funded and bootstrapping works
best if you find that niche but make
sure something exists right there's a
market that's a balancing act I mean if
the market is too large too hot too many
players are already heavily funded or
chasing it your opportunity is going to
be limited in that market so you have to
find that cross between a market that is
there but not so sexy that too many
players are chasing it typically venture
capitalist will avoid anything that is
not on a billion dollar potential at
least and this is a true story actually
in 97 we were exhibiting our software in
a trade show in Las Vegas where I
actually drove from here to Vegas I mean
I couldn't afford a plane ticket it was
cheap and we stayed in this like $15 or
$12 a night hotel where they subsidized
you for gambling there right except that
I didn't gamble so we were Hawking this
is this was the show we were showing
this and we actually found some really
valuable customers of the diamond that
particular event probably got us half a
million in Romania eventually there was
the particularly vent where we got
started in a in effect and a VC saw this
and asked us what do you guys do and
said we are doing this software he asked
how big is his market I mean we are at
zero right we are at zero revenue I took
a wild guess and said maybe ten million
dollars there was a wild guess I had no
idea and this was the thing why are you
so unambitious I begged him this was the
question I had no answer except that I
thought to myself well if I'm too
ambitious then I wouldn't have a
business because I wouldn't be able to
raise any money for all the ambition
ambition is good but you know then you
already tell the story and somebody has
to trust you putting the money all of
that and if I start in this niche maybe
there is a way to find it I need it
exactly worked out that way in the
diamond where we actually pulled in
about two critical customers who each
paid us about quarter of a million
dollars so from that single event we
made half a million dollars and yet we
see told us why he saw an ambitious and
so you ideally want a small niche that
could become bigger right and accept
that this niche we found actually I you
know I don't know wine what reason I had
heard the ten million number because we
found ourselves actually such rating at
about ten million about seven years
later that's exactly what happened so in
after seven years we reached the ten
million number that I had predicted and
there was no growth left I mean we just
completely flat and this was also the
time if you remember the post September
11 the economy was bad things were
generally crappy and
lot of coms were dying or dead and even
our own customers who were labeled
customers before now we're going away so
it was that seven-year itch we faced
with the doldrums and well we had a
business it was profitable the bad news
was it wasn't there wasn't much growth
left I could see the trend clearly I
could see the writing on the wall if you
had stuck to that business we would just
a tiny forever basically
it was clear so here's what we did we
just simply became our own we see at
that point we had a 10 million business
it tagged reasonably you know profitable
it had good cash flow we invested our
own money in our social this time we
became our own VC and bigger market and
we found market segments again this time
bigger but again not potentially too hot
that was part of our mission because if
you find it too hard if somebody else
has raised 100 million and if you are
going up with your like say 5 million
capital how are you going to win so
that's a calculus always in my head I
would always be looking for who's
raising what in this because simply so
that we can condition ourselves in what
kind of money we have to compete with
them there's a lot of times people log
in you in sales and marketing so we
actually found a bigger market segments
and we invested and that took off and we
have to be gain strength in that we
invested again in bigger market this
time this time we had a hundred million
kind of revenue now we could reinvest a
lot more right our scale had grown we
could invest a lot more we reached a
point at some point now really just a VC
money cannot outgive us anymore we can
go ahead to hit against any venture
capital kind of money so that is no
longer a niche and that is so our Zork
are essentially our third act in this
serially but we are still in that first
two we are doing quite well in all first
two the very first one I mentioned the
tiny niche and then the second one we
call it
engine the third one is all they're all
divisions in our company now and of
course though is the biggest of them all
it's the it's playing in the largest
playground essentially every business
could be a customer for so that's how
was the market segment is but to be able
to do that we need capital and we have
succeeded in the first two enough to
bring in the capital to invest and now
Soho has taken off in a big way and this
is the you know this stone was of
co-founder of Twitter it's familiar that
time being perseverance and ten years of
trying but one modification I'll say
twenty years well that's the
bootstrapping story right I'll just give
you a couple of quick tips it's useful
to think of yourself starting at here
minus five not here zero that's why it's
very useful when you're bootstrapping
because otherwise we are comparing
yourself to people who have raised money
it'll always will feel like they're
right of you but when you don't have any
money you will use the mindset of minus
five and if you reach here zero you've
gone five years but you still have only
gone to your zero right and the total
number of people who really care about
your business I mean how much truth can
you handle right you gotta assume that
okay you have to assume that actually
well after maybe five years seven years
we still act convinced ourselves that we
were in business actually we were a
business and in fact the zero is an
optimistic count right because if you
include all the active naysayers as a
negative count but let's say optimistic
keep it at zero right so your business
number of people who care about it zero
that's a good number
you know what that includes the near and
dear to they may not tell you but most
of them actually don't believe in your
business yet keep that in mind because
you know it's useful to have that
realistic mindset
and that way I never got upset for
example you know when my own cousin or
somebody doesn't even know what we do
you ever learn to not get upset right
right after like the first million
dollar in revenues when we could feel
that we are on legitimate business
that's what bootstrapping does to you so
you are because you're constantly
battling that you know existent she'll
don't are we in business are we not and
they you know they have a name for it
the impostor syndrome but a bootstrapper
that's like imposter syndrome squared
you know like you feel that even more
strongly so you have to kind of overcome
that self-doubt and that's part of that
mindset I talked about in the beginning
so that's like the real essence of
bootstrapping here that the mindset of
that you bring in you start and you have
minus five and you assume that nobody
will really care you have to overcome
your own self-doubt and then the
practical advice of your own finding the
market niche all of them so it's
ultimately now I'll go into a little bit
of philosophy you have to realize that
it is a self-discovery process you are
discovering your own inner strengths
over the course of time and for myself
that is absolutely true that it's some
things I learned to do things I never
thought I would be able to do like
actually presenting know I'm an engineer
I you know I only thought I could quote
but under the later I realized I could
do these things and you are when your
self discovery is funded by someone else
what happens is it it kind of becomes
Self Indulgence often which we see right
when people raise too much money too
quickly and the thing becomes
self-indulgent or I know we call this
the or familiar bootstrapping is Mort
sure the trustafarian that's the name
right the self-indulgent you don't have
any kind of self-discipline in the way
you spend money but bootstrapping that's
the nice thing about it you have that
balance between discipline
and that indulgence you are your
discovery is tempered by your discipline
and finally I'll just leave you with
this because you are in Oakland you're
in San Francisco Bay Area it's something
important we are the most expensive real
estate in the world as a bootstrapping
person you have to give yourself all the
advantages you can give yourself because
you don't have many advantages so ask
yourself why am I paying the highest IRR
into the world and and suffering from
the highest cost of living in the world
go figure out somewhere that's cheaper
that's something very important there's
something that I constantly tell people
you don't have to be in a particular
location to achieve your goals and the
the cut your personal burn rate when you
do that you give yourself a longer
runway even with the limited funds you
have so and finally we have actually I'm
rerouting here you have seen our our
trailer outside the Zoho big yellow one
and I have one on once now after this so
you can sign up and this is the DC war
dot t-- o-- one on one that's the URL so
you can go register I'll be here the
rest of the evening so feel free to meet
me thank you thank you
[Applause]